Dean guy slinger walks up to me said
Gillman you got one of those CDs yeah
and I kind of just tossed it to him
right didn't think nothing of it I
didn't know that Dean worked with Jimmy
Iovine so he gave it to Jimmy Jimmy gave
it to Dre and not getting the call my
[Music]
buddy
welcome to and on the [ __ ] road
hotboxing I'm Evan Britain and I'm Mike
Tyson and we got [ __ ] Eminem in
the house shady in the house yeah you
you got you got Marshall right now
JD's like this on yeah uh-huh yeah okay
I'm so excited man if I start getting
weird just stop me it's all good
we did good of the show okay yeah we get
a little weird okay okay yeah no I I
know we met at Kimmel and I didn't get a
chance to like really we can get a
chance to talk you know I'm such a
[ __ ] huge fan I can't even like thank
you
I can't even like I feel like a kid
right now man like this is crazy I'm
Emma I listen to your first album and I
heard you talk about cus oh yeah yeah
yeah man I've seen like pretty much
every documentary every [ __ ] every fight
I've seen like everything that's
available you know I'm saying like I'm
humbled right now I feel like I feel
like a kid again why do you why did you
become who you were why did I become who
I was um well I wanna do this you know
um I just loved hip-hop growing up as a
kid I just you know it was like like it
just it spoke to me more than any other
music I had ever heard before you know
from early like ice-t to
Fat Boys and then LL Cool J Run DMC
Beastie Boys and it just like I don't
know it was like I did I didn't I didn't
first first I was a fan of the music you
know I'm saying before I even thought
about rapping
hello Cool J was the one who made me
like first start writing rhymes and I
was like 12 13 maybe and it sucked you
know I wasn't good but like I had to
keep practicing and practicing pressed I
gave it up for a little while then I
started again back when I was like 15
and started being able to kind of put
songs together and then I just was like
I'm starting to I was never really good
at much else you know so I just I don't
know once I found out I was decent it's
something I just kind of focused and
just you know went for it I was in the
juvenile detention center and we heard
the I'm not a rapper still I was it what
the [ __ ] was that
yeah we heard on the streets in our
neighborhood but we never thought it'd
be on the radio yeah and it was on the
radio we like what the hell with that we
just all blown away yeah music was being
played on the radio yeah you know how
about the fact that rapper's delight'
was like a 7 7 some odd minute song yeah
who had a radio pleaded they played it
from top to bottom like it was so
popular off the hook mm-hmm and the
nucleus jam on it yeah don't don't
yeah I was like yeah I never really I
never really like got into rock and roll
or R&B or blues or anything like that I
just like I you know I've listened to
songs on the radio or whatever my mom
was listening to in the car but once
hip-hop came along I just felt like man
this is like I don't know I just was all
in yeah
hip-hop was can't even imagine me he
gave you cried yeah but being like
but the prototype of hip-hop at the
beginning of it it gave us cried another
our music people talk to it we talk with
being on television being in the radio
yeah yeah private yeah and it's a it's
also like it's just such a if you think
about like how hip-hop from the start of
it well I was there yeah and then it
just like oh you thought in the front of
every hip-hop club you got the [ __ ]
the hope of New York police station out
in front of the club yeah it was just it
was just and if you went to a hip-hop
Club and you're marked it was hell yes
even your neighbor you hardcore bebop
hip-hop and that's what the [ __ ] you
[ __ ] with those [ __ ] like that's
what they said you [ __ ] with them for
you in the neighborhood you [ __ ] with
them [ __ ] for but those those are
people all the criminals are thieves we
all listen to hip-hop the money makers
and everything the crew know the killer
the robbers know all the [ __ ] street
urchins we all listen to that that's all
we listen to and soon as we listen to we
enjoy it but we're spot where we are
surveying everything we're looking at
the people with the jury to coach the
clothes and look and then we're getting
ready to get them after the club is over
that's just what hip I was about all the
while all the thieves were coming there
they enjoy the music but afterwards oh
but we gonna rob yeah that's the hip I
was about yeah once break-in came out
the movie breaking and then Krush groove
and beat Street man it was like yeah I
just put it put the hole it put the
whole culture of hip-hop on the map in
an in an it in a place where you could
see with the music and I'm saying you
had the visual and you had UG you know
graffiti like that's you must say this
is my way out when you saw that I didn't
get good you must say this is my way out
when I started yeah when I started being
able to put songs together and I started
like you know figuring out like well I
might be almost as good as that rapper
you know I'm saying so I'm gonna keep
going and then I start you know just I
learned so much like I asked
how old were you when that started
hip-hop the first time I heard anything
my uncle Ronnie brought over a tape of
breaking the breaking soundtrack in a
hat reckless on it from ice-t once upon
a time a DJ's task was just a play what
more could you ask and I was no couth
cousin yeah yeah yeah
colors was hard yeah my uncle Ronnie
started liking rap before I did and then
he kind of introduced me to it and right
around that time I think yeah the movie
had just come out and I saw the movie
and I was like yo this is I love it
mmm and they just I don't know they just
spoke to me and the way that no other
music had spoke to me before understand
hold Ryu and he first started putting it
out there like started rapping or doing
rap battles well I had a weird
trajectory like I I was afraid like I
was afraid early on like 15 16 years old
I was afraid that to go into any clubs
or anything like that to say my raps
because I felt like I wasn't good enough
yet so I had to get to a certain spot
and then I was trying to like I was just
making songs and uh one day I got a call
from my boy proof and he was like yo you
need to come up to the hip-hop shop and
I was like what what is the hip-hop shop
and he's like yo just come to the
hip-hop shop write something come up
here and proof like I'm a proofing Ani
here he ranch it in Detroit wewe like me
and him came up together and we came up
together but he would kind of go do his
own thing and then I I'd be working like
a factories and stuff like that and
proof was out there like on the grind
and he started making connections and
then he met J Dilla slum yeah slum
village and a lot of the early Detroit
hip-hop that was like
exploding onto the scene like proof was
such a part of that and I got a chance
to when I went to the hip-hop shop I was
like what the [ __ ] he was like you know
I'll clear everybody out I'll have like
ten people right and you rap in front of
them and if they don't like you you know
they're gonna tell you they don't like
you if they if they do like you and they
[ __ ] with you in it you know so I went
there I said to rap I got some people
jumping around and [ __ ] and I was like
okay this might be it for me and then
that's when we start having battles at
the hip-hop shop hmm we was having like
a battle every couple months or
something yeah every every yeah two or
three months but every Saturday I would
make sure that I didn't have to work
till four o'clock because I was going to
the hip-hop shop every Saturday so every
Saturday for me was and this is early
twenties was st. Andrews Hall on Friday
night Saturday hip-hop shop Tuesday
evany showcase and then Buddy the
[ __ ] battle heaven and I Heath here
yeah I said well that's what happened I
started battling and then in the hip hop
shop the first battle that we had there
I wanted but what we was doing proof was
taking names and he was putting him in a
hat like you if you want to sign up to
battle you just put your name in the Hat
he picks a name picks another names
would be like bizarre verse b-flat and
then they go at it and it was you know
and then miiverse whoever I remember one
time I battled conniver who was in my
group d12 but we weren't a group yet a
battle yeah fine and and then I just
started like I met a few people that got
me out of just Detroit and I started
going to I went to like 97 scribble Jam
and I went all the way to the end and
then I lost to this guy named juice who
to this day is still a really good
[ __ ] rapper and I think that it's
he's so good that it's okay that I lost
to him you know I'm saying but the
trapper know this was uh this was
Cincinnati
yeah yeah the scribble Jam was in
Cincinnati that was 97 and then I from
there I met windy day and she put me on
her battle team
she had this battle team that was it was
an event in LA called the rap Olympics
and she put me on that team I went out
to LA and then started bad we got in
that battle at the rap Olympics
went all the way to the end and lost
again last dude
and I was like super discouraged I just
got evicted from my house had to break
in through the through the back of the
house the dude that we is paying rent to
he wasn't paying the rent with it so one
day we took this is literally the day
before I go to the rap Olympics that
that I can thank God for windy day man
because she played for my plane ticket
but that day were like what do I come
home from work me and my boy and we're
like what the [ __ ] all our [ __ ] is on
the lawn oh so yeah so on the victory
man and they decorated your [ __ ] lawn
with your furniture yeah and people was
rummaging through it from the way thank
you [ __ ] yeah yep so that happened and
then I had to break in to the back cuz I
had nowhere to stay so I had to break
into the house through the back window
which was my old window broke in slept
on the floor got up the next day we went
to the rap Olympics and and by the first
prize was $500 and not needed at $500
man and I lost and I was like I was
[ __ ] devastated and then his kid Dean
guy slinger walks up to me and he's like
he's like yo man you got one of those
CDs and I was like yeah and I kind of
just tossed it to him right and didn't
think nothing of it I didn't know that
Dean worked with Jimmy Iovine
so he gave it to Jimmy Jimmy gave it to
Dre and I'm back in Detroit now [ __ ]
right nothing like nowhere to go and I
get the call and I'm like oh [ __ ]
you know this is about to happen well
who's fast then theme fad did to you nah
did not yeah yeah nah but um I just
gotta say like III bro you you are like
a god to me like III bro you you've done
so much in your life man that's like
just so crazy to be the heavyweight
champion at twenty twenty years old
well you're not chopped liver yourself
I'm just saying what I'm saying no but
I'm just saying man like like I I don't
know it takes a lot to be the champion
like it takes a lot and and you know I
remember seeing the first like the first
couple fights when I was when I was
younger when you were first like
starting to really pop I had heard about
yo you were seen this guy Mike Tyson man
he's knocking [ __ ] out in ten
seconds late and the first fight I saw
was uh which was the first fighter so I
think it was Trevor Burbank man you
knocked him down three times with one
punch like like what the [ __ ] and ever
since then it was like it was like when
you fight somebody's getting knocked out
it's just a matter of what round you
know I'm saying it like they come from
humble beginnings you know I have to had
in order to be the champ I'll have to
add to get beaten a couple of times yeah
learn yeah yeah boxing is hard man it's
hard like I've been boxing for like 13
years just sparring just messing around
I mess around with Emanuel Steward
and he's the best yeah yeah all the
champions back then yeah Cronk Jimmy
that was just so [ __ ] a yes man
anybody was coming down here to see the
fighters and stuff yeah
down there he was the man back then yeah
man yeah he was such a nice dude and he
would come over he'd come over to my
house and we spar like twice a week he
bring his boxers from the crunk gym
I mean uh he won't man yeah and they
were really great fighters yeah this was
remember the amateur the frame for the
Olympic those guys were really grateful
yeah yeah man in an Emmanuel was like he
would this was like 12 13 years ago
right so he would he would come over he
would show me the basics and it took a
lot for me to look it took a long
[ __ ] time for me to just learn the
basics right so then he started like a
after a couple months of us doing it and
they were just like you know
up-and-coming kids and stuff like they
would you know didn't just you want to
spar with em they're like okay cool I
got a funny little story so he's
bringing his boxers and this is we're
probably like six months in and he's
bringing his boxers like every week
right and I'm getting my ass whipped but
I'm at least I'm staying with him right
I'm getting some good hits in I feel
really good about myself so one day he
comes over and he brings his boxer from
crunk and I'm in the house and I
remember like I was on the phone or
something so when I came out the dude
that he brought had his headgear on
right and uh and I'm like oh okay I
guess he's ready so I put my strap on my
headgear we're going at it he kicked the
[ __ ] out of me [ __ ] me up so after we're
done we go like three rounds right I
don't think I got one hitting after
three rounds he takes off his [ __ ]
head gear and I said man how old you
he said 14 I'm done yeah man um it's
funny when you said it cuz some fighters
just um they mature early they may be 14
15 they may be the best day ever being a
night
anymore yeah that's just how it is mics
with people they they mature they only
peak at a certain age I paint they're
looking my twenties and stuff
some people peaking at 30 some people
peaking at teens it's just I feel like
if you hit me I probably die like right
now like I still feel like you can I
still feel like you could get in there
and just [ __ ] people up wow I don't even
have them anymore they mentality feel
like I have to [ __ ] kill everybody
family and stuff yeah but I mean I still
feel like you still look like you could
punch a [ __ ] brick wall put a hole in
that [ __ ] yeah I saw recently we 90 was
showing me the video you did where you
was just [ __ ] around and you was
trying to show these dudes how - yeah
yeah and how you jump to the side real
quick jump to the other side like man he
could get in there right now and [ __ ] up
anybody well cuz they make this fight
you know you can fight at any age any
age fighting and fighting yes you can do
forever so you have to desire to do it
Fighting's all about Spears you want to
do you could do that in the age yeah but
it's like but but nobody nobody knocked
people out in the way that you did like
people people got knocked out by other
fighters but it was like when they got
knocked out by hew they got knocked the
[ __ ] out yeah that's how I looked at
every time I heard somebody knock come
out my life gets better yeah my life
gets better yeah and so I love hurting
people that yeah cuz my life is getting
better and I'm getting a [ __ ] girl
I'm getting imagine I'm getting the
plane I'm getting the boat I'm getting
whatever I want so hurt and is beautiful
and my perception of my life at the time
yeah but it's like to be a fighter
though it's like you got a it takes a
special kind of person it takes a
special kind of commitment you don't say
it's almost like you almost have to give
you happiness up to accomplish your
goals
right because you
when you do anything if you want to be
the best garbage can
collected in the way time you want to be
the best in the world at anything it's
gonna be disappointment
yeah a lot of competition and it's gonna
be guys that peak a younger age that
he's gonna blow you away with either kid
and then you're gonna do it I gotta
blows you away when he's old guy here
and then it's going to come to the time
when you're experienced enough then
that's me you know you start blowing
anybody's everybody gifts their time
yeah yeah but it's like you're right
though because like like from me rap is
like a 24/7 job and it takes a lot of
dedication right and you just stay sharp
with the pin and stuff like that but it
just takes it's a different kind of
discipline to do that you know what I'm
saying like and the end and the balls to
get in the ring and fight in the first
place that listen know why I hate to
have anybody gets in the [ __ ] ring
you just think about it as human beings
when fighters do we avoid all of our
life getting into a fight and that's
what a guy that every day of his life he
fights every day with life and we avoid
that [ __ ] yeah it's humiliating if
you're not on the right side and if
you're not fight and he's still went
intimidating yeah you're gonna get hurt
you know some people avoid fighting just
it's not normal people are not supposed
to fight building a structure to fight a
hand and I've developed the fight even
for boxer they break that's what we have
to wrap him up in everything is not
human beings are not designed to fight
yeah we do it all this just part of our
DNA to kill one another just DNA who you
are as part of a any form of murders is
a form of self-hate yeah you know I mean
you kill another person so it's just
it's just nicked me and stuff how you
feel about yourself yeah it's
interesting though it's like you know
boxing is just like a like coming up
when I was a kid I got my ass kicked a
lot I fought I lost I fought I won you
and I'm saying and it was it was a night
and there was a time it was a point in
time where I started getting enough
fights and winning enough fights that I
felt confident until I started learning
some of the fundamentals of boxing and
I'm like I don't know [ __ ] I know
nothing like we all believe in here that
if you get involved with boxing
it's a tough man sport boxing is not a
tough man support a tough guys gonna get
hurt in boxing I talk funny at the end
of the day yeah understand them this is
a thinking man sport only the smartest
one yeah
when you get a certain level yeah only
the smartest would tough guys man this
is not a tough man sport yeah no I shot
you look man I I also know you got a
heart so it's like you [ __ ] somebody up
and then feel bad later yeah and you'd
be late because out you know you'd be
nice to him after the fight like I don't
like I hate you during this fight and
then I don't hate you anymore and I
actually feel bad cuz you might die now
that's who you are that's know that's
our fear yeah right there with vicious
be ferocious to the fact that we've lost
before and we've been disappointing
before we don't want that feeling
anymore yeah
the foot the fact that took that we have
to go back to Brownsville you have to go
back to seven mile that's [ __ ] fear
that's our biggest fear to go back where
we started
yep oh yeah subconsciously that's our
biggest fear yeah I have to see those
people who we grew up with if I made it
and I [ __ ] up I'm back in DC yeah yeah
Milton Berle used to time I lost a fight
you know I was the president birthday
well tell you the press was you know
doing bad it's going back to Brownsville
you made 30 million dollars why are you
depressed yeah he is he's old Jewish got
these walks in and guys can't understand
why these guys lose the fight for 30
million 20 million dollars a night he's
crying yeah he is he'll understand if I
want to watch he never went to the
phrase if I wonder why two minutes is
what I usually I used to grab my house
in Beverly Hills right hey boy you want
to say you you said we really in this
really entertain your
you're emerging in rap we thought that
was beautiful everybody all
nationalities and everything we have to
we had to say you're the best you put
you put it down we watch you battle we
watching that battling but we watch you
them compared with the best we watch you
two songs with jay-z what you do all
those guys when you got really ill oh
thank you man yeah thank you you know
yeah one no sir they say yeah you saw me
before I didn't have all these awards
before but you see all these guns it's
worth before yeah oh yeah yeah before
all the weapons book marshal step in the
door yeah yeah yeah that was the biggie
song yeah you know [ __ ] him listen are
you conscious that you know you rapping
like Jamie do you know you gotta play
for you know you gotta put it down cuz
if you don't put it down people I feel I
may be [ __ ] on you I mean that's how
I feel
anytime I get on a song with anybody
it's like man if I don't try to like I
have to you know just having their
hunger still and trying to like like you
said it's not about it's not about the
money all the time right so it's like
when you when you lose a fight and you
get depressed is because your
competitive nature and your competitive
spirit its wounded right because your if
the reason that we started doing this
because we're not good enough for goes
in your mind not good enough
y'all better than me and the [ __ ]
kills you better than you you believe in
your head that you're God to you the
better whatever you believe you are yeah
yeah yep
yeah man you know used to open a
hangover hey listen man I was just very
happy to do that I was like 280 pounds I
was on cocaine I was I was just doing I
had my prostitute girlfriends at this at
that [ __ ] and this was a trailer with
me I was just living a [ __ ] life back
then I hadn't listened when I did The
Hangover I didn't know I went to the
clubbing clubs in Vegas they let me in
all the privacy you know and so when I
went in this private spot saw these
white people in his white crew and I was
gonna do people but then I saw those two
girls
who go the two twins what's the name Oh
the Owen would say Owen twins so I
thought the two Oh half of one I thought
I saw one of the Olsen twins out there
with these guys I'm in the just Oprah's
clothes to them and then the guy the
bodyguard lets me and the guy buddy go
for the club because he knows me knows
I'm over it with money he lets me in a
weird children and stuff where I cooked
up and we're drinking and then they look
at me and they somebody comes over say
hey you're gonna move with you into it
we're gonna move with you I said when he
said two years a [ __ ] I know that and so
I'm gonna I'm on this movie I'm doing
this set and stuff and I'm just a mess
back then so I do this movie and I don't
think this movie [ __ ] numbers I'm high
all the time and then I'm in a
restaurant I come off the restaurant you
see one of those buses you know the tour
bus they see me they must have went to
the movie and sort of previous cut the
movie wasn't out yet and then when they
saw me must have been like 30 all cars
the bus I saw you the movie and then my
friends and I'm no longer what they say
hey we got family we're back we're back
yeah yeah and then that's been a rap
ever since and I'm talking to my friend
and he and I was out in the club I don't
know what club Oh at it was a movie
theater and I went there neighbor I was
all over me and they gotta produce
hangover Todd Phillips who did the Joker
he listened he said listen I'm I feel
proud I said I'm a part of this because
he saw everybody coming up to me it's
he's got my part of this did you know he
was proud that it's very buddy was
coming up to me and then next thing you
know he was I can tell you what we doing
next but it's just looking good friends
I still don't know
yeah it's dope too because like like I
you know I was like holy [ __ ] Mike can
act you know I'm saying like and then
seeing the undisputed yes man and
hearing you tell them stories that I'm
like I
don't want to know about this yes a new
distributing an underlying yeah I'm the
story why did I do that yeah hell yeah
ready to do round two
really yeah all the time to so much
betting around when we did this all
listen this is really how do you do this
I knew you had so I'm on the show and
iFit good night and it's 4,000 people
and when I think I'm a harbor they all
get up and they come to the stage and
he's gonna touch me and I don't know the
security is not run up I wanna run
that's right it's just overwhelming and
[ __ ] that people think that way about
you and in my mind I always had a little
selfish thing I said these people think
much about me they must not be [ __ ] why
would you think about me good I'm [ __ ]
ya know I went through a lot of that
[ __ ] too growing up as a kid and just
feeling like I wasn't good enough for
anything like whatever I did I just
wasn't good enough and yeah man it's a
psychological thing I think that once
you for for anybody who doesn't feel who
feels like that right like I just feel
like I'm not I'm worthless I'm not
nothing in this world
anybody who feels that and then find
something that they're actually good at
it's like I think that's that's what
makes somebody go for that so hard if
you know I'm saying yeah like I'm never
get it I was never getting nothing I'm
good if this you know most the most
successful people never lived in history
I megalomaniacs
but they got a little self-esteem yeah
nothing much about this stuff but they
think they're God in another hand to
write you know those are the most
successful people they're always
challenging that doubt yeah making a
doubt inconceivable that's not true but
they still believe is doubt right even
though they prove that it doesn't stop
them from succeeding but they still they
still challenged and it still bothers
them
they still believe there's nothing and
3me billions of dollars they still feel
they believed in that [ __ ] that's just
how the mind [ __ ] limit yeah people
also think to like money just buys
happiness and it absolutely is not the
truth you know I'm saying like you got
to be right inside otherwise none of
this [ __ ] means nothing no absolutely
they get everything there this is this
is something this is everything [ __ ]
this hmm this is everything I waste my
[ __ ] life for this is everything
yep yeah yeah om you just blew the
[ __ ] roof off the Oscars how'd that
feel they still ask you to come I lose
the [ __ ] dopest thing I've seen in a
long time dude thanks man but I said but
I'm gonna tell you why I'm making that
face okay cuz when I went out there
everything was cool right I go through
the first verse and you know they they
had a pact where your mic pack yeah the
mic pack yeah that you wear you know the
clip onto your belt and then you got the
in ears that go in your in your ears
right so you can hear the sound and I'm
rapping and all of a sudden I see
between my legs the [ __ ] pack
swingin man I was like so then I try to
stick that [ __ ] in my and I'm like no
pockets back [ __ ] so I'm lyrics while
I'm doing this and then I'm like my
front pocket [ __ ] by that time the
songs over oh and I'm like man what the
[ __ ] we rehearse for that [ __ ] I know
the words to lose yourself right yeah
yeah but we were Hurst that [ __ ] extra
extra extras just so we didn't [ __ ] that
up and then that was the one thing we
didn't plan for and of course it went
wrong and I'm like [ __ ] yeah dude
nobody saw that
really suck no you killed it bro you
[ __ ] killed thanks man thank you
hell yeah thank you I know it's amazing
yeah cuz I got creeped out I'm like I
don't want to [ __ ] see this [ __ ] I'm
gonna just get angry yeah
[ __ ] Haley is 23 what that was that like
his boyfriends and stuff his babies he
not babies nope
just boyfriend yeah and yeah she's doing
she's she's she's doing good she's made
me proud for sure she graduated from
college 3.9 Wow and for her man yeah
thanks awesome how does it feel you have
a 23 year old I was just listening to
Slim Shady
yeah and listen yeah it's it's it
definitely is crazy it definitely is
crazy I have a I have a niece that I
have helped raise to that's kind of like
a daughter pretty much like a daughter
to me and she is 26 and then I have a
younger one that's 17 now so when I
think about my accomplishments late
that's probably the thing I'm the most
proud of you know is that he's being
able to raise kids you know most guys
like us successful and stuff that
suppose we have a kids are [ __ ] up you
know yeah they never had the life that
we hadn't ever struggled they never know
struggle without struggle there's no
progress
yeah and that's why they don't put grass
for their own struggle yeah yeah it's
definitely important to keep your kids
grounded when there's situations like we
have right it's very important yeah oh
hey brother thanks for coming in really
you got to get back to your shoot it's
all good man I'm I'm so honored you
would even think to do this man I can't
you know I told you I was gonna fan out
fan out on you and if it gets weird just
stop me it's all good your [ __ ]
Mike Tyson man your [ __ ] in the
now it's an Internet listen let me tell
you something right I've been those
hammies I'm in the streets with um
all-star there
some [ __ ] in the tree and I remember
better - how Fortin Detroit but you know
I listen so and I'm from brown with a
similar to the tree what's the
possibility of you being a seven mile
from seven mile now you hear and I was
that how what's the what's the
percentage that that that's what I think
what's the how do a guy in seven miles
get out here how do you get out here you
don't got [ __ ] and you know a destitute
ya know how does that happen because
it's ordained by the universe me and
this guy man chenine went through a lot
of [ __ ] like when we were when I we were
kids ourselves right and we were still
looking when I met denying he had just
started making beats and we met do it
through a mutual friend IQ who was a
rapper who was actually on my infinite
album and IQ introduced us and then we
man we grinded until like he went
through a lot of this wheeling through a
lot of the same things together coming
up right so it was like we and we did it
together we worked the same job we were
roommates we had you know I'm saying we
lived in houses together you guys
success became because of your lifestyle
success and fame all that stuff comes
from lifestyle you know I changed my
lifestyle I stopped getting I asked top
three I stopped every dance a [ __ ]
girl I never had no girl when I was
boxing yeah I was too young I didn't
have a good time like 19 18 years old
you know but up that's all I focus on
that's where I didn't wanna dance wanted
to fight it all I did watch fights all
day just from a guy from 1892 now yeah
all day that's all I digger that's all I
wanted to be yeah that's all I knew I
don't know etiquette about fight baby
didn't you ask me about fighting I could
tell you how did it begin how did they
start I knew everything about fighting
yeah I remember what was there I saw a
documentary where customer I used to
make you he would call out numbers oh
yeah the woolie yeah like man I could
never live to do that that [ __ ] is that
[ __ ] was crazy yeah he was crazy but
yeah you know a lot of his father left
him because he's so overbearing and so
perfected and if you allowed to say you
have to be crazy to to be with this man
but I wanted to be the best so bad yeah
and only he could do it no way he could
know why the end there's no one could
inspire me like him I wanted those guys
I'm I'm a dark person I come on my dark
world so nobody sitting a white
[ __ ] no one can inspire me like
him he inspired me to be better than
what I was there's no way I was going to
be if I wasn't like Tyson
badass [ __ ] Brownsville Brooklyn
I still wouldn't have made it because
I'm that was just browse the book he
made me believe I was - I was the best
fight of the world ever produced
yeah but you did it oh yeah but you did
it and you were the best fighter yeah
but in life that's not a good way to
think and fighting this great but in
life is reckless
isn't that interesting yeah to be
successful in one field is disaster it's
in another field right yeah would you
you were great in rap but in life you
will kind of shake yeah oh I have an
eighth grade education I you know I know
the pressure or something
boom there in your face and the judge
people are judging you you gotta lows we
have a little weird self-esteem any
we're not people are judging the same
things about it and we get defensive and
we get defensively playing to their game
but still even though we do that this
gives us our attention and we get
reputation for being crazy and unstable
and drug addicts and stuff and then we
go through the whole recovery thing well
listen the best thing that ever happened
to me involved with the recovery
programs and I met great people but I'm
what am i know what i am i am i am a
relapse specialist you know I have to
relapse even for five years straight
then I relapse and my relapse is like my
real that starts with thinking or me
jerking off a lot of some
you know I know that's just dropped me
off looking at my porn that I saw
jerking off and did not start looking at
[ __ ] pregnant I look at people I
never thought about [ __ ] stuff who's
real close to me and that's just who I
am and I mean those are my list of my
habits and those are my flaws and [ __ ]
yeah oh the people around me man my
people think I'm [ __ ] nuts you know I
used to sorry for the people who are not
nuts at around you yeah you're not if
you're not crazy in this crazy world I
really feel sorry for you
yeah I think my circle of friends is
definitely somewhere in the ballpark of
my insanity if noticed be friends with
me how did we live in this well how do
we find our purpose you're born and most
of us are born [ __ ] in bad situations
everything why what's wrong with us
while we here mm-hmm
why do they put us in why do you why
we're not living like these people and
stuff and these people look down on us
and we were around these people these
people can call the cops on us and the
console and listen to us and listen to
those people yeah please don't say hey
I'm garbage of nothing my true life
showing me that I'm nothing and then you
run to somebody who you think is
certainly he tells you great things
about yourself and then you think you
agree because this great guy told you
creating the budget and then the whole
perspective of your confidence go to
another level proof
that's how proof was to me yeah man he
was uh he was a godsend to me because he
I know that I would not have made it
without knowing him because he gave me
like not I mean he he he co-signed for
me when I went to this shop when I went
to every show cuz he co-signed for me
everywhere I went and people respected
him his name meant something because
they respected him because usually crazy
listen when custo those South African
guys hey listen we have a black young
man this house he's our family you treat
him the way you treat us and he told
anybody around there all of the way
here's all these guys of power positive
this is
son this is the and look my head was so
bad he shoulda did he never told me I
was the [ __ ] that you're not gonna make
he always said I was superior than
everybody you know that trip he told me
I'm better than everybody reason why
those people bother cuz they're jealous
of you he never had put doubt in my mind
that I was [ __ ] up even though I
believe that he/she is shattered and be
me of my mind I thought of a demigod
it's crazy because that's the one thing
you needed the only thing you needed in
your life to feel like you was special
no that's how proof made me feel I'm not
like my confidence was so low I had such
a low self-esteem
I was just so good when I first met cus
and I saw the house imma walk up these
white [ __ ] then he kept talking
to me and gave me self-esteem and then
he made me want to be his watch if
anybody say their bottom I would kill
them I believe you hmm no I'm saying I
believe you I believe my mind just like
that anybody disrespected he me it made
me feel something he made me feel like
something I never felt before
and I said that if anybody disrespect my
was [ __ ] kill them yeah then together
that's how you show your love by killing
somebody or hurting somebody for
somebody
yeah I gotta ask you when you was going
into like them early fights right when
you first started coming up and you're
walking to the ring what like what that
what is that [ __ ] like really orgasmic
is almost like um like you felt delight
did you feel like part of you nervous
like tense but the other part like you
gonna kill somebody I'm not nervous I'm
scared I'm scared yeah cuz I'm a scary
guy because I've been picked up I'm
honest I've been abused all my life
people did anything they wanted to me so
I have natural fear I'm not being safe
yeah that's just my that's who I am
natural it's know it's in my life that's
who I am
so now I got it with this weird
self-confidence
violence and stuff so now I'm sadistic
and I'm afraid I'm gonna get hurt
yes animal now yes I was like I gotta I
gotta hit this guy
I gotta hurt this guy before he hurts me
I feel yeah and now I have to do they
have to do spectacularly for more people
want to see me do it again and more
people did hurt doing the most
spectacularly I heard them the better my
life would be yep and that's how my
mindset was that's crazy cuz love
hurting people other fighters he loved
breaking the ribs that I thought that
the chief ball he is loved he he is
wonderfully how people work under those
circumstances yeah and I just I just
never seen nobody like hit so hard
before like I don't like that's gotta be
something like like what is that like no
um and their credit for my punch in
speed but it wasn't my punches it wasn't
my punching power that it was the
accuracy and that fast so I got the I
got the punch here before the other
people does that the hard punches got
there you know sometimes the Harley
Foreman's a hard puncher but he has
pounds you hit you in the shoulder the
arm gonna [ __ ] you up I'm in some
precise and you hear me everywhere I
hate you the reason and normally I get
the right results most of the time yeah
it's like like the way you sit down on
your punches and when you throw those
hooks to the body and [ __ ] for the guy
don't see the punch to the punches that
knock you out
ya know that's crazy though
oh yeah well dude you gotta hurt them
and can tell you something this is
really good we know you don't do this
stuff yeah this is really cool you don't
have to thank me man it's equal like you
come in here is like such a [ __ ]
we was like we were talking about it and
it was in the treatment Mike Tyson like
someone knocks him out and I'm like I'm
like if we get Tyson like that's when
top of the [ __ ] food chain that's the
I thought we feel about you with him
this is the biggest [ __ ] and I had to
do it everybody Tony Robbins I'll be
[ __ ] interesting guys and stuff this
is the best part
this might be my biggest interview right
here
yeah man you're the man dude thank you
thank you bro
Thank You Man and you're not no guy
somebody gave anything everything you
got was [ __ ] not even giving you
[ __ ] slave for it you know I mean
yeah yeah the only white guy they knows
would like to be a [ __ ] yeah nah man
it's a few I got that present a [ __ ]
[ __ ] babe doing me black you treat it
better than me I mean you know we all
got our story yeah we do yeah you do
yeah but yeah man I'm super honored i I
can't believe we were able to get you
for this video it's awesome man
I'm [ __ ] on earth everything in life
is no it's always mapped out from my
birth to our death it's the size
ordained to be the plan to be this be
marshals to humble to be huh how's that
feel being free care being sober you
don't have time we have time looking at
me looks great I'm used to it now
hey buddy buddy first thanks for
watching this episode of hot boxing
thank you - mmm thank you to our brother
here for joining yeah man
until next time I'm Evan Britain I'm
Mike Tyson I'm Marshall Mathers and if
we didn't have to do a video right now
I'll be sitting here probably asking
like questions for another two hours
do it again we do together I do I really
appreciate thank her I want to
[Music]
[Music]